[Musique]
il y a Dina TV qui vient de publier à
l'instant que le député abasfal a été
arrêté mais c'est
[Musique]
énorme ils veulent faire peur ils font
des arrestations toutes azumutes pour
pour pour pour faire peur pour faire
taire il y a plus de liberté
d'expression il y a plus de il y a plus
de trois de liberté parce que aller
manifester c'est c'est un droit c'est
c'est un droit d'ailleurs fondamental
garanti par la Constitution du pays et
maintenant si maintenant euh la personne
sort pour aller dire non pacifiquement
encore et là son arrestation est
automatique
[Musique]
parce
queprre
[Musique]
le risque que nous avons c'est d'être
arrêté et d'être mis en
prison c'est
tout sur la base de délit de diffusion
de fa nouvell diffamation des
publ voilà les dél qui systématiquement
utilis pour faire taire toute critique
contre on
criminalise finalement
l'espace civique le seul fait d'exercer
des droits CIVIS qui sont tout à fait
normal dans une nation démocratique
devient passible d'infraction
[Musique]
crimin